nos dicen hay 10 estudiantes en el club
de poesía esta semana cada estudiante
escribió dos poemas que representan la
expresión 10 por 2 y nos dan estas
opciones pausa en el vídeo y vean si
pueden resolverlo vamos a resolverlo
juntos nos dicen que hay 10 estudiantes
en el club de poesía y que cada
estudiante escribió dos poemas yo usaría
diez por dos para expresar que cada uno
de estos diez estudiantes ha escrito dos
poemas por lo que hay un total de diez
por dos poemas y si vemos las opciones
lo encontramos en la opción c si vemos
la opción de el número de estudiantes no
aplica porque el número de estudiantes
es 10 y no 10 por 2 y el número de
poemas que escribió cada estudiante es
la segunda parte de la información que
nos dice que cada estudiante escribió
dos poemas esto tampoco es 10 por 2
resolvamos otro ejemplo un poco
diferente ahora nos preguntan qué
problema puede resolverse con 3 por 8
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
por su cuenta antes
lo resolvamos juntos muy bien veamos
cada opción para ver cuál se resuelve
con 3 por 8
elena tenía 8 piezas de chicle muy bien
ella comió 3 piezas en la escuela espero
que no se las haya tragado ya que sería
un problema cuántas piezas de chicle le
quedan a elena ustedes usarían una
multiplicación para resolver esto veamos
ella tenía 8 piezas de chicle y se comió
3 cuántas piezas le quedan me imagino
que quedan afuera de su cuerpo pues para
resolverlo yo restaría 3 a 8 no
multiplicar y a 3 por 8 descartamos la
opción a porque no vamos a resolver esto
multiplicando 3 por 8 benito tiene 8
camisas muy bien también son las camisas
que yo tengo él va a la tienda a comprar
tres camisas más cuantas camisas tiene
el ahora yo resolvería esto con una
multiplicación veamos él tiene ocho
camisas y va a comprar tres más por lo
que sumó tres para calcular el número de
camisas que él tiene ahora yo no
multiplicaría por tres por lo que
descartamos la opción b veamos la opción
c hay ocho chocolates en cada caja
miguel tiene tres cajas de chocolates
cuántos chocolates hay en total esto es
interesante él tiene tres cajas de
chocolates vamos a dibujar estas cajas
una caja dos cajas tres cajas y en cada
una de ellas hay ocho chocolates vamos a
dibujarlos en cada caja 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y
8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8 y 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8
ahora sí quiero saber cuántos chocolates
hay en total tengo tres grupos de ocho
por lo que resolvería esto multiplicando
3 por 8 esta es la opción correcta
hagamos otro ejemplo
gerardo va a sembrar un jardín en
primavera esto es algo bueno él planea
sembrar siete plantas en cada surco él
hará ocho surcos que expresión puede
usar gerardo para calcular el número
total de plantas que necesitará para su
jardín pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo muy bien voy a hacer unos
dibujos en verde porque estamos hablando
de plantas hay siete plantas en cada
surco y él planea hacer ocho surcos uno
dos tres cuatro cinco seis y siete siete
plantas en cada surco y vamos a tener
ocho surcos vamos a copiar y pegar esto
hay dos surcos tres surcos cuatro surcos
cinco surcos seis surcos siete surcos y
ocho surcos no tenemos que calcular los
pero una forma de pensar en esto es que
hay siete plantas en cada surco y hay
ocho surcos de plantas por lo que si
queremos calcular la cantidad total
multiplicamos 8 por 7 que corresponde a
la primera opción
no multiplicamos 8 por 7 por 7 y 8 7
definitivamente no nos dará el total de
plantas de aquí por lo que nos gusta la
opción de 8 por 7 y terminamos